I'm matthias from datatec and
this video is about parametric
and non-parametric tests
why is the topic
even interesting you want to calculate a hypothesis
test
but don't know exactly what the
difference between a
parametric and a densely
parametric test is
and you ask yourself the question  when you use
which test
of the want to calculate you must first
check the prerequisites for the hypothesis test
one of the most common prerequisites is
that the data used is subject to a certain
distribution mostly the
normal distribution
put simply
your
may be distributed parametric tests
uses
e.g. the test uses the analysis of variance  where the
dps correlation
is your data not distributed
normally the non-parametric tests
are used
e.g. the male user is in correlation or the sbm
but what about the other requirements of
course you still have to check whether there are
other requirements f  For the
respective test,
however, there are generally fewer prerequisites for non-
parametric tests
than parametric tests.
do you want to use parametric tests at all?
parametric tests are usually
stronger than non-parametric
tests  example men and women earn
equally whether
the new hypothesis is rejected depends,
among other things,
on the difference in salary between the
two groups
and on the sample
size a few metric tests are smaller differences in salary
or a smaller sample
to reject the new hypothesis
therefore if  it is always possible to use
parametric tests
with which
you can easily
calculate both the non-parametric and
the parametric
tests of data
trepte click on the statistics calculator and
add your own data to this table
then click  On this
day, simply select the variables
for which you
want to calculate your hypothesis test and
datatec will then suggest the appropriate
hypothesis test,
e.g. income and gender.
Here you can now select for which you
want to calculate parametric tests or non-parametric tests
if you calculate the parametric test
the culprit is calculated independent samples
if you
uncheck it so you want a non-parametric test
calculator the male user is
calculated it
the same applies to all the other
hypothesis tests
he liked the video and we'll see
you again soon